في ايران التمرد الشعبي ضد النظام لم
يتوقف يوما وان قلت الاحتجاجات المنظمه او
اعداد حشود المتظاهرين وحتى تجمعات الطلاب
الا ان غضب الشارع الايراني الذي اشتعل
منذ سبتمبر الماضي لم يهدا لحظات شكل جديد
للاحتجاجات تشهدها شوارع طهران تقف وراء
النساء الالاف من الايرانيات في طهران
يمشين اليوم في الهواء الطلق دون ارتداء
الحجاب الزامي شكل من اشكال العصيان
المدني من غير مرجح ان يطيح بالنظام ولكن
يقول كثيرون بانه سيكون من الصعب احتوائه
في المستقبل وفق تقرير
السلطات في ايران حاولت قمع هذا السلوك
الجديد وامرت الشرطه بفرض غرامات على
النساء اللواتي يخالفن قواعد اللبس وكذلك
فرض عقوبات على سيارات الاجره والمطاعم
التي تسمح بالدخول دون حجاب
خطوه لم تؤثر على قرار الايرانيات فتجربه
الاشهر الماضيه كانت بالنسبه لهن نقطه لا
عود
كذلك الى غضب الايرانيين الذي لا يزال
يتصاعد مع رفض النظام الاستجابه الى
مطالبه ما يشير الى ان الاحتجاجات قد
تندلع مجددا في اي لحظه قريبه وبشكل
الاقوى وانف ربما خاصه في ظل زياده لتضخم
وهبوط العمله الايرانيه ما ادى الى تفاقم
الازمه الاقتصاديه يوما بعد يومين ملوك
الشيخ العربي